do you intend to claim odell beckham jr
and adam to your team uh you'll have to
wait and see how we how this all goes
but um at this time um you know i don't
know i've been on the practice field i
don't know what's going on with it as
you as you would think
we're aware what's going on and we've
been involved to understand it and
competing to know what's happening um
and we'll let you know as it all happens
i'm gonna wait
so i didn't say yes or i didn't say no
but that's just because
you'll see
[Music]
pete carroll that means yes okay that
means yes they're talking to ho ho dale
and they're trying to figure out some
things that's what that means jack
yeah i think i think they're going to
take their swing in the bat right here
russell wilson getting healthy i mean i
you got to think about trying to stop
d.k metcalf tyler lockett odell beckham
jr simultaneously that's a lot of
firepower and with how top heavy the nfl
has gotten like if you think about the
weapons kansas city has the weapons that
a team like tampa bay bucks have it just
has become almost nba like how many
premier play makers can you have on the
outside and that just becomes such a
headache for defenses so they are
definitely one team let me float one
other team out there to you right now
the green bay packers i'm hearing
through the rumor mill that they have
interest in odell beckham jr if you're
one of these contenders would you have
interest in object absolutely you said
it green bay seattle the saints the rams
okay because the rams don't have a lot
of depth at the wide receiver spot the
chiefs
the titans because you think about julio
jones is always hurt so you don't know
when that hamstring's gonna get a little
tight so yeah odell beckham and i've
talked to odell beckham this offseason
and you know he seems like a different
guy you know it just seems like he's a
lot more humble he just wants to be in
the right situation but the number one
thing he has to understand is when he
comes in he's not going to be the man
he's going to be one of the guys and if
he can accept being one of the guys
until he really proves himself and
separates himself then he'll be fine but
in order to get a guy like that and the
teams that i named they have a strong
quarterback uh personality they have a
strong locker room they have a strong
head coach those are the type teams that
you need you need a locker room that is
close-knit that has some good veterans
so they can pull adele odell aside and
say look it's not about the numbers it's
not about all the stuff it's about
winning football games we respect you we
know what you can do let's go win some
games
i'm with you i'm with you and i think
that a team will take a chance on him
and so it's an interesting debate
because you're going in my head i'm
thinking it should have worked in
cleveland if he is a different guy and
all these things are true he's there
with his best friend and his former
teammate and jarvis landry you got a big
personality at the quarterback position
and baker mayfield that seemed like at
least initially that he really wanted to
make it work there it didn't work there
so i'm going okay so what what is the
perfect scenario is it matching up with
a guy like russell wilson is it getting
with the guy like derek carr is getting
with the guy like aaron rodgers and can
odell beckham jr not be the man can he
not be the man i haven't seen that yet
so it would have to be something brand
new if he's able to take a back seat
yeah i mean goes back to what we just
talked about yeah he has to come in and
he has to be
one of the guys in the locker room and
odell you know odell man odell's been a
superstar high school college pros he's
been a superstar if he can humble
himself and fit in in the locker room
he'll be just fine but
you know it's it's going to take a level
of sacrifice and if you want to win
football games if you want to be part of
something special you got to sacrifice
can you imagine how much media be there
in green bay right now if they sign
odell beckham jr i mean green bay this
place is already about gone to explode
everything they have going on you put
odell beckham jr up there all right
let's get to number two which is the new
england patriots can the patriots win
the division at this point who would
have thought we'd already be having this
conversation by week 10 can the patriots
win the east what do you think
hey all i said is at the beginning of
the year that you know the patriots can
push buffalo for this division you think
about the patriots are starting to
really hit that stride they're playing
with a lot of confidence the defense has
played a lot better the offense has kind
of been you know just kind of right
there but mack jones he's getting that
experience they're running the football
i'm so glad that um coach belichick is
implementing andre stevenson i mean he's
a big physical guy he runs guys over you
know he wears down the defense i love
damien harris
like buffalo can't run the ball and you
know if you go to new england in
november december and it's snowing you
got to be able to run the ball there's
no way josh allen's going to come out
there and pass for 2 300 yards on those
the snowy days you got to be able to run
the football i think the patriots are
right there they got it they got a
really good chance and they're going to
continue to get better
they're just going to keep getting
better they're already good that's
what's scary now you're starting to see
a little bit of chinks in the armor
there with buffalo as well so they've
won three in a row right they beat the
jets they beat the chargers they beat
carolina they took dallas to overtime
when dallas was playing their best
football and if you think back to the
game against the bucks they were a field
goal away from beating the bucks so they
have played with some of the best teams
in the league at this point a rookie
quarterback i just think a rookie
quarterback's going to feel more like a
sophomore by the time we get to the
playoffs given the length of this season
i think he's going to feel and play like
a sophomore quarterback and if mac jones
is doing that i have no reason to think
that this team is going to be not only
at the top of the east but at the top of
the afc and i don't believe that a
player like tom brady wants to go play
his former coach and bill belichick ever
again and i don't think you know the
thing about a team like tennessee i
don't think they want to play the new
england patriots in a single elimination
tournament i can't think of a team that
i would want to play less than new
england based on the way they're all
coming together right now
yeah and coach belichick he's the best i
mean if you need a one-game game plan i
mean he's the guy i mean think about
what he did when tampa came in town
against the patriots i mean tom brady
struggled they end up winning the game
but tom brady struggled it was one of
the best game plans i've seen him draw
up
so you see those two matchups with the
bills coming up so let's get to san
francisco this san francisco thing the
wheels are just falling off and it
almost feels like every week it just
gets a little bit worse they had a whole
bunch of backups coming into town a
chance to go get it felt like it was
going to be an easy win just to give
them a bit of hope and they couldn't
even pull that one off so is it panic
time right now for the 49ers
i wouldn't say panic i mean you still
got a bunch of games left but it's
definitely concerning and you know what
kyle shanahan and john lynch is going to
have to get together and decide what is
the future of this organization because
right now having two quarterbacks and
trying to figure out what you're going
to do with one the bottom line is this
you gave up the house to get trey lance
after this year jimmy should be gone
you're not gonna win a super bowl with
him get him out of there give trey an
opportunity to be there bring in a
veteran quarterback that he hasn't
a guy that can just come in just in case
he gets hurt maybe a marcus mariota
something like that but allow him to
beat a starting quarterback and to me
you know i'm looking at john lynch i'm
looking at a lot of his draft picks and
you know the way kyle shanahan has
treated brandon nyuk i mean he's a first
round draft choice you got to be careful
how you talk to guys and things like
that because they're not going to want
to play for you so we'll see what
happens i don't think it's time to panic
but it's definitely concerning and if
i'm kyle shanahan and john lynch i'm
concerned as well because you think
about some of the players that they
brought in mohammed sunu is your third
wide receiver how can mohamed sanu be
your third wide receiver i mean he's an
older guy he just
it just shows you the level of talent
that they have
yeah solomon thomas another high draft
pick top five draft pick that just did
not pan out at all really i mean they've
lost five out of five
he's kind of up and down
that's another one right they've just
kind of been doing this i haven't heard
a lot of optimism just in terms of
watching practice or watching games for
that matter about trey lance and if trey
lance doesn't wind up being a great
quarterback a franchise quarterback
i don't see a scenario where they don't
clean house if trey lance doesn't wind
up being a franchise quarterback are
they really going to get a chance to do
it again they pay garoppolo 125 million
they trade everything to go up and get
trey lance if he doesn't pan out and
they continue to lose games as a result
is there any world where that's not it
or they wouldn't have to just call it at
that point with this regime
i would assume that if this does not
work out okay and we have to figure out
too is that one year is that next year
if that doesn't work out or will they
give him two years to see if trey lance
works out we don't know but at the end
of the day
as much as i can because if initially at
the beginning of this year i was against
playing two different quarterbacks
now i see that there could be an
advantage to playing two quarterbacks
because now the young player he gets
experience and now the defense has to
adjust to his speed his athleticism and
all the things that he could do and it
puts pressure on jimmy g so
i'm i was against it i think i'm for it
now i think they should play him a
little bit more
it's i am too it's such an interesting
situation though especially with how
well mac jones is playing to tie two
conversations together with all the
rumors that that's really who shanahan
wanted was mac jones the media and all
the naysayers sort of talk him out of it
he winds up picking trey lance mac jones
ends up looking great even though he
fell in the draft and he goes to new
england now trey lance just hasn't
showed promise as fast so
it would really be a difficult end to
somebody who is kind of a wonder boy in
terms of coming in as a play caller in
shanahan and he's just hit a major major
speed bump go ahead ron
hey bro i just i couldn't imagine the
type of pressure that's on that young
man trey lance cause you know they gave
up the house you talked about it jack
they gave up everything for this guy can
you imagine every single time he goes in
the game the type of pressure that's on
his shoulders the type of weight that he
carries and that's why i say it's so
important for them next year they got to
get rid of jimmy g and start
implementing trade to build him up even
if you're losing you still have to build
up trey lance you still have to build up
brandon iu these are your young players
this is the foundation of your team if
you don't build these guys up you're
going downhill and you're going to end
up fired
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports